ich möchte kurz beginnen mit dem
Rückblick vielleicht erinnern sich
manche noch als Ende Februar Putin
angefangen hat in die Ukraine
einzumarschieren es war ein großer
Schockzustand im Land und es war sofort
klar das wird auch was mit unserer
Energieversorgung machen erobert Habeck
wurde da vier Tage danach von der ARD
Journalistin gefragt ob wir denn nicht
auch noch mal den deutschen Atomausstieg
überdenken müssten weil zu dem Zeitpunkt
waren gerade drei Kernkraftwerke frisch
abgestellt drei liefen noch die sollten
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt jetzt Ende des
Jahres abgeschaltet werden und habe
gesagt zum überraschen dieser dieser
Journalistin in die Kameras es gebe da
keine denkt Tabus und er sagte er würde
diese Frage prüfen und sie nicht
ideologisch abwehren
was danach geschehen ist haben einige
Leute verfolgt es gab ein langes hin und
her und man hat es gar nicht so ganz
verstanden am Ende hat Scholz und
Machtwort gesprochen dass jetzt drei
Kernkraftwerke noch ein paar Monate
zweieinhalb länger laufen sollen das
wird uns nicht viel nützen aber immerhin
der Verdacht dass die Grünen diese
ideologisch ohne die logische Prüfung
ernst nehmen war ungefähr so glaubwürdig
wie wenn die metzgerinnung versprochen
hätte wir prüfen den Vorteil der veganen
Ernährungsweise und genau es ist auch
gekommen diese ganze Prüfung war von
vorne bis hinten eine Farce und
stellenweise waren es auch wirklich
Lügen die da stattgefunden haben und das
habe ich zusammen mit einem Kollegen der
Welt am Sonntag jetzt ganz aktuell mit
Dokumenten aufgedeckt und die Sache ist
an euch nicht zu Ende die Sache ist noch
nicht zu Ende aber erstmal kann man es
so klar sagen Robert Habeck hat gelogen
kann man ihn vielleicht in einzelnen
Aussagen kann man es sagen zum Beispiel
zum Beispiel als er als er gesagt hat
wir haben wir haben kein Stromproblem
das war so eine Schutzbehauptung wir
müssen es nur ums Gas kümmern mit dem
Strom ist alles in Ordnung also
zusammengefasst der der Bürger hat keine
ehrliche Bewertung bekommen sondern die
Ideologie von Herr harback sollte
gestützt werden und dementsprechend hat
er das alles so verkauft und wurde alles
so hingebogen manches verschwiegen
manches auf Zeit gespielt das war so ein
ein wirklich ein ein Taktieren alles
aber so getan als wäre es eine sachliche
Prüfung und das werfe ich Ihnen auch vor
wenn die gesagt hätten wir sind die
Grünen wir sind schon immer gegen
anti-ag wir können das jetzt nicht
machen sonst wird Herr Trittin den
Silvesterabend werden wir eben versauen
auf denen sich schon seit Jahrzehnten
freut hätte man vielleicht Verständnis
für gehabt hättest aber so aber so haben
sie ja so getan als wären sie jetzt auf
einmal pragmatisch und unidologisch was
sie überhaupt nicht sind das hat sie
auch dazu gebracht zu recherchieren weil
sie gesagt haben das kann ja gar nicht
stimmen dass er Habeck es Ideologie frei
prüft ja
wenn man das so hört also das Politiker
die Lüge glaubt ja ehrlich gesagt eh
keiner als Bürger aber der Fall hört
sich schon schockierend an wie würdest
du ihnen einordnen naja also ich weiß
nicht ob Robert Habeck hier gelogen hat
das glaube ich nicht ich glaube sogar
dass diese Äußerungen die sie zitiert
haben aus der ARD seine tatsächlichen ja
Zustand wiedergegeben hat den Robert
Habeck war glaube ich ein bisschen
offener am Anfang als seine
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke und der
Rest der Grünen also ich glaube schon
dass er sich hat vorstellen können dass
man dann Kompromiss findet aber er wurde
dann zurückgepfiffen von Steffi Lemke
was natürlich auch viel sagt über das
Machtverhältnis innerhalb der Grünen und
es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Gründen
Robert Habeck möchte noch was werden er
möchte irgendwann Bundeskanzler werden
er möchte kandidieren als
Spitzenkandidat er musste damit umgehen
dass ein Jürgen Trittin sie haben ihn
erwähnt natürlich vehement auf die
Barrikaden ging eine Steffi Lemke ihn
zurückgepfiffen hat die Umweltministerin
Annalena baerbock sich auf Parteitag
noch in Bonn hingestellt hat und kein
Zentimeter weiter mit uns in Sachen
Atomkraft gebrüllt hat also oder gerufen
hat und insofern musste er von dieser
Position schnell wieder runter und sagen
nein nicht mit mir was mich viel mehr
interessiert tatsächlich ob er wusste
dass er ein Kompromiss wird eingehen
müssen ob Scholz ihn über stimmen wird
als ein Parteitag seine flammende Rede
da in Bonn gehalten hat gegen die gegen
den weiter weiterlauf der Atomkraftwerke
der drei und das ist natürlich
interessant ein Punkt noch ich glaube
die Verantwortung hier einfach zu
delegieren Richtung Bundeskanzler dass
man sagt also ja ich bin es ja nicht
gewesen Bundeskanzler hat entschieden
das funktioniert natürlich nicht ne als
Wirtschaftsminister bin ich dafür
verantwortlich muss mit den Konsequenzen
leben
aber auch am nächsten Tag ein Tag
nachdem ich diesen Parteitag hatte mich
dahin gestellt habe und gesagt habe
nicht mit uns diese Entscheidung dann
hinzunehmen und zu sagen naja im Grunde
können wir damit gut leben das geht
natürlich auch nicht das zeichnet
eigentlich hätte in diesem Moment
zurücktreten müssen weil gesagt hat
Freunde der ich lasse mich in dieser
zentralen Frage nicht überstimmen auch
wenn es nur drei Monate gewesen dann
machen wir jetzt hier aber auch ein
Fehler das war im Grunde war das ein
großes politisches Theater weil was ist
de facto passiert wir haben da dieses
angebliche Machtwort von Olaf Scholz da
ging es um ein einziges Kernkraftwerk
was in
Niedersachsen stimmt das kann man nicht
das kann man nein das kann man nicht so
sehen es gibt hier eine zentrale
Festlegung bei einem Parteitag der
Grünen in dieser Frage in sich nicht zu
bewegen und diese Frage das wird
abgerechnet
egal völlig egal ob eins ist eine
Grundsatzfrage die Grundsatzfrage der
Grünen und das wird am nächsten Tag
einkassiert durch ein Machtwort des
Bundeskanzlers das kann man nicht neg
schon als ein Atomkraftwerk darstellen
oder als drei für ein paar Monate das
ist eine zentrale dann ist es ja noch
schlimmer wenn es eine abgekarte ist der
war ja dann ist es ja noch schlimmer
aber da freue ich mich hat es gebraucht
weil er dann seine eigenen Partei sagen
könnte Papa hat mich gezogen konnte
nach der Geschäftsordnung der
Bundesregierung gibt es das Machtwort
nicht das ist sozusagen ein Begriff der
ja von außen kommt sondern es gibt halt
die Richtlinienkompetenz und die werden
sich zeigen wie stark der Kanzler ist
und ich habe
als diese Regierung sich gebildet hat
schon mehrfach darauf hingewiesen dass
wir eine Kanzlei Demokratie waren aber
keine mehr sind weil erstmals mit einer
wirklichen 3er Koalition im Bund
natürlich sich die macht auch verlagert
weg vom Kanzler hin zum
Koalitionsausschuss und zu anderen
Gremien die dann
zusammenkommen und gewissermaßen die
Kompromisse die möglich sind Piloten so
dass also die Entscheidung des Kanzlers
etwas ist was nur im äußersten Notfall
als Einsatz der Richtlinienkompetenz
gebraucht werden kann und ich war etwas
unglücklich darüber dass es in einer so
eigentlich peripheren Frage dazu kommen
musste ja wir sehen aber die eigentliche
Frage was ich auch ganz also ich finde
es auch falsch jetzt darüber zu
debattieren ob jetzt diese zwei oder
drei dann noch für zweieinhalb Monate
laufen darum geht es nicht natürlich ist
es gut dass wir durch den Winter kommen
und das Strom jetzt damit stabiler wird
und die Preise auch gedämpft nein es
geht mir um was anderes was Fach mit den
nachmiete April was ist dann auf einmal
meine frage einfach mal als normaler
Bürger glaubt hier wirklich einer in
diesem Land außer irgendwelche Leute die
vielleicht auch ein Pinocchio und Biene
Maja loben dass wir wirklich unsere
Wirtschaft unsere Industrie auf die wir
bauen müssen mit ohne diese
Atomkraftwerke weiter halten können ob
das wirklich irgendeiner außer nicht
irgendwelche Damen und Herren die
meistens noch nicht erarbeitet haben in
ihrem Leben also ich glaube da nicht
dran und ich kann es mir auch nicht
vorstellen dass das funktioniert dass
man mit so einer Energie Stahlwerke und
und und betreiben kann das glaube ich
nicht ja wir brauchen die Kernkraft
zumindest für eine Übergangszeit und die
ist garantiert länger als Mitte April
2023 was jetzt der großes große
Machtwort oder Kompromiss was immer ist
das ist ja ein Irrsinn wir haben
Deutschland hat gerade keine Strategie
wie wir die Energie versorgen unseres
Landes sicher und bezahlbar für die
nächsten jetzt beginnen Jahrzehnte
überhaupt halten und organisieren aber
keine Strategie weil dieses ganze Gerede
von von von von von von erneuerbaren das
ist alles Zukunftsmusik weil jeder weiß
es geht dauert noch lange und es geht
nicht so schlimm woher soll Strategie
auch kommen ich meine die Politiker mit
denen wir es zu tun haben werden in den
Parteien geschult als Taktiker sie
denken gewässermaßen um die nächste Ecke
herum aber so etwas wie Strategie gab
grenzt strategy wie die Amis das nennen
das ist nichts was ihnen in die DNA
hineingegeben wird wir haben im Prinzip
in dieser Frage durch die Bank weg ein
Problem eines strategischen Defizits in
der politischen Klasse das Spiel genug
Zeit ja aber dann sollen überlassen
können
ihre These ihr Thema heute Abend ja
viele Politiker kokettieren ja gerne mit
dem Satz den habe ich auch schon ganz
oft gehört erst das Land dann die Partei
wenn ich das aber jetzt heute von ihnen
höre wie viel Wahrheit ist denn da noch
dran ist da nicht für jeden Politiker
fast erst die Partei dann das Land oder
sogar erst ich dann die Partei dann das
Land
Robert habe komme fast ein bisschen leid
er ist ja ein sympathischer Kerl ich
habe ihn sogar ich saß mit ihm schon mal
beim Bauernhof im käsebauernhof also da
war ich noch lokal schon ist und er war
noch Kandidat für irgendwas es ist ja so
kommt jetzt sympathisch rüber ist auch
in der Bevölkerung bestimmten Bereich
noch sehr beliebt aber er ist in er ist
da tragisch gescheitert er hätte die
Chance gehabt an dieser Kernkraft Frage
und zwar in dem Moment als die
Netzbetreiber gesagt haben diesen Winter
kann es Stunden geben wo wir in
Deutschland den Strom abschalten müssen
in bestimmten Stadtteilen so
stundenweise ja das gab es seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg in Deutschland nicht
damit es Strom jetzt nicht
zusammenbricht damit es nicht zum
Blackout kommt was die Katastrophe wäre
das wird so
er hätte die Chance gehabt das wollte
ich noch zu Ende bringen es so wie
Joschka Fischer damals beim Kosovo Krieg
zu machen und auf diesen Parteitag
seiner Partei mit Verweis auf diese
Notsituation liegen ja die Netzbetreiber
assistiert haben schriftlich und auch
wenn
seiner Partei seine Partei zur Not
anzubrüllen und ihnen sagen eure
Anti-Atom Vergangenheit schön und gut
aber davon müssen wir wegkommen auch
wegen des Klimaschutzes dafür weiter
dafür war er zu feige und das wird ihm
glaube ich auf die